the Joe Rogan experience you guys the
fact that we can do this oh my god you
gather get blasted publicly blast hit
public take it I'm floating on until I
find you I bury myself deep inside your
heart
[Music]
you won't feel a change will just become
the same and never spend a single day
[Music]
the other oh yes I treated them the same
as you and I like the salty T is they
cry and many went from many to a few
I need you lead it baby
his near
[Music]
keep your hand on your chest don't let
me whisper in your ear it's best to keep
on walking lock the door when I come
knocking
[Music]
never
maybe you'll be shocked by this
admittance things are rarely ever they
see oh I don't mean you harm by my
existence
just let your tired I'm asleep into
dream because I'm easily death baby and
is me
keep your hand on your chest don't let
me whisper in your ear it's best to keep
on walking out the door when I come
knocking
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah mine's the voice you never wanna
hear
[Music]
[Applause]